thank you
[Music]
hey are you ready to get tripped out
with the boys no what's up check this
out
Delphi Indiana okay a city
with uh 3 000 people population
okay Township that's a little ass Kitty
what that's a joke it Rhymes it Rhymes
you're welcome dude you're welcome right
in 2017. in 2017 these two girls two
teen girls no just keep laughing they
were murdered on a hike come on
that's not funny that's not funny
thing another cheese so this is a tiny
town right 3 000 people in this town in
2017 the two teen girls went on hike and
they were murdered but the case still
went cold after five years no suspect
how were they murdered I mean it was a
hiking killing right it's hard to tell
if you're in the woods and [ __ ] we have
to know the nature of the murder I think
they were just like stabbed or something
so they're they're just hiking and [ __ ]
yeah man you know maybe that makes it
even crazy it's like a whodunit it's
like those it's like knives out when
it's like a smaller group of people
Everyone becomes a suspect but do you
think it's even people in the town well
that's the question so here's what
happened so that's back in 2017 right so
the two girls they're they're uh you
know they've been murdered their
families are trying to look for answers
they even though the case went cold and
they're not even working out that much
the family's still trying to find some
kind of solution they go and print
photos of the girls at like the local
CVS and you know try to post around try
to look and ask questions for the town
and eventually
uh
this year a suspect was found and
charged what who was it
is a family member is it random or
here's a hint I I said it when I just
described what happened it was a family
member family member nope oh I missed it
I wasn't listening
did they kill each other no it was a
nice fight it's two it's in what I just
said it's two sisters that had a knife
fight no they didn't kill each other the
Killer is is in what I just said it's
it's they went to go print photos from
the print guy the Xerox copy machine guy
was the guy printing the photos at CVS
how how did they know
they caught I don't know they didn't say
how how they figured out the case but
they caught him and they realized he was
the CVS guy
oh my God the same guy that was on that
hike at that time who killed him you
know what my sadistic ass was like I was
gonna I was gonna crack a stupid joke
because it's like whoever smelt it dealt
it right it's like if I were to murder
somebody and try to get away with it I
might also be the guy printing the
photos to pretend you know what I mean
like why aren't you guys finding this
murderer he was wait he was the one that
was printing it on his own no he works
at CVS and then the parents came in and
said print this out but they didn't know
that that was the guy can you put these
spots and he's like you gotta Stop
Printing these men you're never gonna
catch them
he got arrested and they named the
suspect the parents saw it and went
that's the [ __ ] CBS guy there is a
God isn't that the most torturous thing
you can do to the Killer
is just you have to be confronted with
their parents who consistently if I knew
that was the killer I would do this just
to [ __ ] with them
I would keep and I'd just be like man I
don't know where I just have no idea
where to draw it out no idea like this
is happening so like uh and then I'll
just be like he was such a good person
you would you wouldn't go you wouldn't
be like man if I ever found that person
I'd probably like
after phalanges one by one dip their
[ __ ] body in acid while they're still
alive you wouldn't do [ __ ] like that no
because I don't want to scare my
suspects too much to where they run away
and they're gonna be they're gonna know
they're gonna know yeah one of those
people would be like hey you know what
like you seem like a nice guy come over
for like tea I want to show you old
photos you should come over and then
they'll be like oh no all right
RX time next time it's time and then you
come by and then you could be like dude
I made you some cookies because you've
been printing out all these things thank
you so much you know
find out that he was hiking with them or
he was just so happening like yeah I
want to know the motive they don't know
they just know that at that time the
girls disappeared and were killed that
this guy's the suspect they just know
that that maybe he was just out there
trying to kill somebody
they just got the dude so it's it's
that's why because CVS isn't paying him
that well and he's like I'm mad it's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] justifying again
what do you mean for profit no he didn't
murder them
he's just frustrated you know he doesn't
look like a printer though he looks like
a murderer just printing stuff imagine
that guy he does look like us he does I
was was picturing like a teen kid
printing photos so you know when you're
at TVs you don't need a person to
actually print it yeah there's just a
person working there that will tell you
like oh you just got to do this and then
you know it's a machine right yeah he he
actually has his farm tech license
so he has like a dark room and all that
[ __ ] works at CVS he like does the
pharmacy oh Pharmacy yeah how he was
able to kill both like he and then it's
a stabbing right ah I don't know
and then the other one could run away
and he looks like a fat dude okay fine
so is he gonna be able to chase after
the other one like how did he get both
that's what I'm curious about probably
just a big strong guy from the bat he's
from the back and he's no no two knives
next did they ever find a murder weapon
no necks two next Who's Next
it actually doesn't even say what the
weapon was it just says oh you could
have shot him murdered while hiking yeah
he could have shot him both and
empathize for one second because this is
kind of [ __ ] up that feeling that the
parents must have had after the fact
because you wouldn't go and print the
photos you would print the photos
recognize and Associate it have that guy
in your database for whatever reason
subconsciously and and then they had to
have a moment of realization imagine
that moment of realization where you
were literally face to face in
interaction it's not like a suspect
that's like why would you do this to my
daughter it's like I interact this
[ __ ] I could have killed the [ __ ]
that killed my kids that [ __ ] must be
[ __ ] crazy wait so he's just a
suspect but they didn't prove that he
did it or oh but I know he did it that
[ __ ] did the case is not over he
wore an orange jumpsuit he did it but
after five years of no suspect and
they're and they picked this guy I'm
sure it's a pretty good [ __ ] lead I
wonder yeah how that came to be like how
how they investigated and they're like
oh it was this [ __ ] the time to
go through all 3 000 people
it's just process of elimination was it
you no it wasn't you no it wasn't you
maybe would that guy just went hell no
that's you interesting why are you so
desperate
that guy yo that is crazy though I was
thinking about that that's why like
if it I when I go to the woods I'm
always armed because I don't know like
well if it was if it's not a human it's
an animal okay that's true you know so
like your weapons of choice when you go
Joe's armed right now guys is this
[ __ ] surprising he has weapons
everywhere how many weapons you got
right now
with he hit one two
there you go oh that is a weapon
probably don't even even need to take it
out actually it's just dramatic whoa we
don't want to get demonetized here I
know man we can't be showing up
Contraband oh you're the judge I'm the
judge he's Thor bro yeah so it is crazy
that uh in a town of 3 000 people
like for that a case to go if you got a
town that small I feel like things like
public hangings are still cool yeah
basic thing is this guy is also married
with a daughter of his own oh like he's
just a regular Dude too see that's what
it's like so fast not fascinating but
like you really want to know motive you
really want to know like fascinated dude
it sounds scary dude a little
fascinating because it's like
I don't know I think that's why people
are so fascinated with murder in general
people are fascinated with them curious
look at Dahmer dude who literally says
stop saying faster what about saying
look how fascinated I am withholding the
guy that was uh Mary and his wife was
like wow this took me by surprise
uh Peggy Bundy
I think it's that one Ted Bundy Ted
Bundy yeah I think it was that one hey
oh the girlfriend well like yeah he had
a girlfriend and he was like no he was
but it and then but the but the weird uh
phenomenon was every time they fought he
took out his anger on a girl outside oh
interesting so every time they fought he
would go go out to like cool down or
whatever and then he would commit that
crime where he would murder a woman all
this stuff so his girlfriend they've
been with each other for so many years
and she was just like no a great dude
but like we never yeah his Outlet yeah
wow he took it out on other women or
that was just his like kind of cover-up
Alibi because he got another human being
that's like there's no way I was with
him the whole time I'm the same type of
girl that he would do this to you know
that could be his whole mask yeah yeah
if you're that if you're that wild and
you can do it that long and you're that
successful at it it's fascinating
he was gay
you know what I mean yeah that's true
you know when there's psychologists that
try to look or like criminal
psychologists that try to look into the
mentality of a lot of killers and they
try to pinpoint the root in which like
things sort of went wrong do you believe
that some people are just innately
[ __ ] up I don't I think that it is
Nate uh nurture oh it's always nurture I
think that you can be wired a certain
way but it's your environment to to make
you have a vendetta toward the world so
like your story if you had a bad story
like you're not just born with a desire
to just murder a [ __ ] ton of people I
don't believe that I believe in most of
these cases there is a story of trauma
there is a story of whatever because no
one talks about the bright side of
people with these conditions that might
be diagnosed with being psychopath or
whatever right but when you're in the
right environment you channel that in a
way that's like extreme sports you might
be a CEO of some sort yeah you might not
be a killer but you do have the
condition but you do have human
um what do you call it Choice like you
choose to make the decision of
expressing yourself through murder this
this might be a little [ __ ] up but I
really feel like Jeffrey Dahmer just
wanted love too he keeps on saying
because he admitted he admitted
because he admitted like he was like I
don't know why I was doing it but my
mother left and I I wanted to he's like
oh I don't I just want to be with them
he keeps saying that yeah at least for
now there's no story where there is a
serial killer who's had a great perfect
childhood and nothing was wrong and then
all of a sudden they're just murdering
tons of people there's always some sick
twisted [ __ ] that happened to them or
their stories kind of [ __ ] up and then
they started going down this path like
they might be predisposed with their
lifestyle and how they grew up is like
the thing that sets them off but that's
what I'm saying there might be when you
say predisposed it might be like 10
nature yeah and like 90 Nursery you know
what I mean like I do think that just as
much as like uh we don't necessarily
always explain why uh this is the
biggest person that ever grew and this
is super tall or like this person grew
only this you know what I mean if
there's that much difference and
variation in things that are beyond our
control there's gotta be a little bit of
that too in a different way you know I
think people are wired in a way where
like hey uh you don't have a guilty
conscience when you kill like there's
that's that's true right but then yeah
it's also up to them to decide what to
do with this ability but imagine because
if you're super tall like you were
saying you you could like Anthony is
very tall if he goes through doors he
has to you know like that down every
time but I don't wanna if it's my house
I don't want to duck down every time
that's why it's like if I my empathy is
like I don't care about killing people
all the time every day I gotta not kill
people yeah let me kill people sometimes
yeah and it's cool that you're standing
up for Jeffrey dahmerman yeah he likes
to kill people I think that's why Dexter
is so fascinating right because Dexter
is like someone who is a serial killer
but for Justified means where people go
yeah good job
[Music]
foreign